[Musique]
oui bien à paroles aux actes antisémites
sont morts lundi puis aujourd'hui on le
sent le printemps est à nos portes
réellement une petite laine de mapei
mais il fait très beau et très chaud en
après midi si ces moments-là de l'année
où je me ramène je me rapporte justement
à certains des événements près marquants
de ma vie qui se sont pas aussi au
printemps qui se passe annuellement au
printemps où on va à new york pour le
forum permanent sur les enjeux de tonnes
c'est un moment qui était
transformateurs pour moi j'ai commencé à
y aller avec la wapikoni mobile pendant
justement en plus des moments très
importants dans les dom au moins les
premiers moments j me suis rendu là il y
avait vraiment tout l'enjeu au taux dé
stephen harper du canada l'europe du
canada justement l'effacement des
communautés autochtones les femmes
assassinées disparu les pensionnats la
langue tous ces enjeux-là était nouveau
sur la place publique et depuis eh bien
il faut partir du narratif canadien on
reconnaît les pensionnats on reconnaît
les enjeux qui nous touchent et ses
enjeux l'avez jamais entendu parler très
clairement partagés justement entre
plusieurs nations au forum permanent sur
les autochtones d'ailleurs c'est la 21e
session qui se passe cette semaine
jusqu'au 6 mai dans les communautés
autochtones beaucoup de gens feront
justement à new york pour pouvoir
échanger sur des enjeux qui les touchent
celle qui m'a vraiment allumé sur le
fait que ça avait recommencé en rien
c'était ellen gabriel qui est allé
hélène qui est très très très grande
protectrice des langues et surtout de la
ranking et les rangers elle est
présentement à l'onu et ça ouvre quand
même 2022 la décennie pour les langues
autochtones donc ça va faire partie des
sujets discutés mais c'est pas le seul
il voir des sujets discutés d'un peu
partout dans le nom des communautés
autochtones de tous les continents sauf
l'antarctique bien ça s'arrose on
s'entend pourquoi sont représentés donc
ça doit même permis à beaucoup de jeunes
ou de personnes notamment de rencontrer
des autochtones d'un peu partout dans le
monde mais mes premières rencontres avec
des amis par exemple qui ont été très
révélatrice sur le fait qu'on ne peut
pas se rencontrer on ne peut pas
échanger normalement un peuple
autochtone mais qu'au forum permanent on
pouvait et là se présente des gens avec
leurs regalia leur fierté qui part dans
leur langue qui protège qui essaie
d'amener des sujets la première heure
des sujets urgents justement sur des
scènes internationales qui permettent
aussi de créer un grand renfort à part
des autres communautés et je mexplique
présentement beaucoup des sujets on voit
dans l'actualité c'est des sujets puisse
discuter quand même il ya quelques
années au forum permanent je parle la
disparition du caribou je parle des
aires protégées traditionnel versus des
aires protégées autochtone toutes ces
enjeux les la protection de la langue
sont discutées entre communautés
autochtones en personne aux communautés
autochtones et surtout personne
d'intérêt qui veulent faire avancer le
dossier mais tout le monde ensemble à
l'onu c'est quand même un moment qui non
seulement donnerait partance à nos
enjeux mais en plus nous permettre de
pouvoir se rencontrer tous ensemble tout
temps autour d'une même table et c'est
fantastique comment ça fait avancer des
idées comment ça donne justement du jour
de contenu à nos luttes et de voir que
nos expériences similaires viennent du
même preuve des mêmes problématiques
souvent comme des problématiques de
colonisation et bien ça nous permet de
pouvoir faire une stratégie autour de
comment de faire justement ces modèles
qui oppriment beaucoup de nations
d'automne donc vous imaginez comment
c'est fantastique mans
excitant intellectuellement
je peux pas arrêter de réfléchir toute
la journée quand les lobes cette année
ce qui est intéressant à voir sait aussi
qu'on va commencer à demander un
rapporteur spécial sur les droits
humains à l'onu de venir se présenter au
canada pour voir et pouvoir discuter
justement des corps qui ont été
découverts au canada des enfants qui ont
été au pensionnat donc ce sont des
enjeux ou
on sent qu'il ya on peut pas demander au
canada de s'inquiéter lui même on peut
demander à un enquêteur notre diva sera
portée en matière de droits humains
autour d'un enjeu qui touche les
communautés autochtones au canada par le
passé ça a été nécessaire pour beaucoup
d'autres sujets donc ça devient un petit
peu une monade pour avoir l'attention
internationale sur des sujets qui sinon
canada pourrait world juster alors
n'hésitez pas à suivre dans les
nouvelles justement tout ce qui se passe
autour du forum permanent allez voir sur
les sites web regarder et partager aussi
avec les gens qui sont au talent et
l'expérience de ce que c'était c'est
quelque chose d'assez fantastique et en
plus il ya des années qu'on appelle des
side event des événements sur le côté
qui nous permet encore plus de
développer justement ce réseautage en
communauté autochtone donc un peu
jalouse ici mail au moins en échange et
du beau soleil mais ça ça serait
vraiment quelque chose à mettre sur vos
agendas pour tous ceux qui s'intéressent
justement aux enjeux autochtones peu
importe de quelle nation ils sont ça
devient un peu un excusez moi
l'expression d'un grand niveau pour
pouvoir savoir ce qui se passe un peu
partout alors n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
justement des commentaires des questions
et je vous souhaite une très belle
semaine